so when I say digital addiction to you
what does that connote to you well it
connotes that's something that we're all
experiencing which is that we've gotten
into the habit of constantly reaching
for our gadgets so although a doctor
will say well that's not a real
addiction you don't have real withdrawal
it acts just like it because that habit
is so deeply entrenched that we reach
into our pocket before we even decide to
do that you know we find ourselves with
something in our hand before we even
know and then we say how did that get
there
why are we always reaching for our
devices how does that habit get formed
well we're rewarded every time we reach
into our pocket right it's like um you
know we have biology that drives us to
find the things that help us to survive
so when you see something that's
delicious on the horizon your attention
heads that way and then you start
walking that way or for mating or if
it's something that's threatening or
frightening you had the other way well
we are hunter-gatherers you know as
we've developed as people and we also
hunt and gather information so we reach
in our pocket but we also never seem
satisfied no matter how good the
information on the device is welcome to
life as a human being we can't get
enough you know whether its food or or
security or houses or information we're
built to want more and so we're always
reaching for something so how do we if
we wanted to attack this challenge how
would we do it
well the the reaching in the pocket the
habit is formed at a very low level like
you really can think of that as as
biology happening we're we're kind of
rewarded for that behavior so it gets
reinforced so it becomes a habit but the
thing that makes people so special the
thing that makes us so fantastic is that
we get to make a choice so we can feel
impulse
and stop and say yeah but I don't really
want to do that even though part of me
is urging me on but that's not what's
best for me today is the key to getting
a hold of this problem thinking about
the long term versus the short term in
other words I know that at the end of a
day of endlessly checking my phone for
whatever reason I'm gonna feel
diminished in some fashion and to keep
that present rather than the impulse
which is the thing that usually runs to
the front of the line right it's a very
adult deferred gratification kind of
thing you know you know that if you eat
six desserts no matter how delicious
they are later it's not going to be such
a happy feeling inside it's no different
with your smartphone tell me a little
bit about interruption so when I'm
writing for example something it's
difficult it's hard I sort of self
interrupt to kind of get out of whatever
difficulty I'm doing but every time I
interrupt then I have to get back on
track and in terms of I guess what I'm
trying to do is chart for people some of
the ways that this constant interrupting
constant attention shredding can can
make us less productive less happy
what's some of the downsides are to this
every time your attention moves to
something else whether you're distracted
by something internal whether your cell
phone beeps and you have to pick it up
or somebody's at the door
it takes energy to shift that attention
and it takes energy to come back you're
starting over really so you're losing
resources you only have so much and if
you spend it with constant interruption
you're not as productive if we want to
rewire our habits how do we how do we do
that we say we talk about self
gratification what else can we do to
rewire our habits so the first step is
just deciding that there's really a
payoff there for you so you know
avoiding the cell phone and seeing how
you feel gives you the information that
you need so now you know that you feel
better when you don't do that
then you have to start paying attention
it doesn't help you to notice when
you've already pulled it out and turned
it on but can you catch yourself right
at the moment where that first impulse
starts to be felled and can you use that
sensation as a reminder to pause for a
minute today I've gone without
technology and increasingly over the
course of the day I've had this hunted
feeling this itchy feeling I want to be
back into what's happening to me
well you you're stepping in the way of a
habit it's hard you know if it were easy
everybody would successfully die it have
a stable exercise program you would only
do things that are healthy for them but
but actually changing these habits is
really hard they're there for a reason
you have habits so you don't have to
figure out what to do at every moment so
they save you a lot of work but
sometimes they lead you places that
you'd really rather not go if I want to
if I want to insert a new habit in my
life how long will it take me well you
can start today but it's going to take a
month or six weeks until you've created
a new habit it's not so much that that
old habit really goes away it's still
there it can still be activated but
you're forming a new habit that replaces
it so we've talked about interruption
let's talk about the benefits of
attention and focused work when you're
not interrupting yourself what are you
getting well
you by having a sustained stable
attentional focus you have more clarity
about what you're doing you are actually
more attuned even to what's happening
inside so thoughts ideas emotions that
come up are more available to you you're
more creative and you're more productive
talk to me about the balance between my
digital devices have delivered me some
of the most intriguing interesting
connected wonderful parts of my life so
I wouldn't want to be done with it how
do you find that way to balance right
lots of people say we'll just get rid of
them it's not it's not going to work
it's like saying well we all have
diabetes and we're overweight so let's
eliminate food from our country good
luck with that
I mean they are fantastic we've built
them for a reason but we do need to find
a balance that's healthy and
i you can clock it you can put an app on
your phone that tracks how much time you
spend on these various you know other
apps and so on but I think if you're
paying attention you know you can feel
it right at the end of the day you know
and and so since you're trying to do
this for a lifetime not for this week or
this month I think that you have to
reestablish what matters to you set a
goal not a goal of hours or minutes but
a goal of functioning well and feeling
well and then pay attention to what
happens so is the first step in dealing
with this digital interruption stepping
back and sort of assessing the larger I
mean it feels like it's stepping back
and sort of assessing your larger
worldview weight noticing what's
happening and then realizing that it's
not exactly what's best for you and then
deciding to make a difference so if I
want to build balance I need to decide
to make a difference I need to recognize
it's gonna take some time what other
elements are there in terms of trying to
build this balance well I teach
mindfulness so I'm a big proponent of
mindfulness for things like this because
mindfulness is really a process that
trains your attention to be more stable
so you notice better so you're able to
catch that impulse before it becomes you
know the cellphone out of the pocket you
can pause at a time when it still makes
a difference so mindfulness training
yourself in mindfulness is really like
you know exercising to make your body
healthier it's something that you do
over time to enhance the capacity that
then helps you so if I want to be more
mindful what do I do well you know it's
a little bit like saying well I'd like
to be more physically fit and and I
could say well go to a gym John come on
but but it's more complicated than that
you'd have to find a way to train
yourself and so maybe you'd use an app
maybe you'd go take a class maybe
you'd read about it and just try it on
your own lots of people have tried all
of those things meditation is also a
useful part of mindfulness Oh mind
fulness is a euphemism for meditation
you know we used to talk about
meditation which was for weirdos you
know people who were practicing some
other religion at some other time or
place so mindfulness which is really
just a kind of meditation is is a word
that's become fashionable you begin
trying to create this balance we have to
start long before we are ever reaching
in our pocket right and we're
essentially rewiring the way we approach
the day right and the and the word
rewiring is apt because you really are
changing fundamentally changing the way
that your brain works which means
changing the way that it's wired what I
love about the conversation we're having
is that it is that they so much of when
people talk about this digital
connectedness or whatever they think of
little tricks in ways you can change
your phone you're talking about going
down into the deep che love the way we
behave as human beings to kind of build
a new way of approaching life to handle
this kind of very powerful force in our
modern world you know why there are all
those little tricks out there because of
these devices you turn on your device
and say eliminating my addiction from
and then you read like pages and pages
of little tips and the thing is that
they're interesting so you read them the
next time the next time and the problem
is that they don't work with whatever
I'm looking at it is a niche I cannot
scratch it does the more I look at it
the more I look at it and and is that
right or is that just my it it's like
any habit if you eat a lot of sugar you
crave it drinking smoking these are
things that give us an immediate
reinforcement a hit of dopamine and then
we look for it and then we crave it
so dopamine is nothing special really
but it's just the system in your brain
that signifies reward like so you know
when I say that this is rewarding or
you're wired to do this dopamine is part
of
that wiring you know in a particular
part of the brain dopamine is released
and it feels good whatever it is it
feels good
so that's rewarded reinforced and is
more likely to happen the next time so
to get blazed down grooves and they get
deeper and therefore you need to fulfill
it more and it gets it builds on itself
it builds on itself and then it becomes
a habit that's so automatic that you're
not even making a choice you're not
making a choice to do that behavior
anymore
it just happens so when somebody checks
their Instagram account and they see
their friend has liked their picture why
does it make them feel so good because
nobody posts their awful moments on
Instagram so when you look at social
media it seems that everybody in the
world has a life that's better more
exciting you know more appealing than
you so sure you think oh I'm just smooth
I'm like not you know doing anything
right look at all these beautiful people
succeeding so when somebody likes your
picture or your comment you feel a
little burst of sort of psychological
affirmation yeah dopamine you might call
it right because we're built to look for
that kind of gratification and you know
the best way to train a person or an
animal for that matter to do something
is to not reward them constantly but to
reward them intermittently so you get a
little like and then you don't and then
you get it and you really get hooked
into that I do sometimes feel when I'm
using my phone like the rat in the old
pellet experiment that I'm gonna get the
little pellet of food is that I mean
that's what's happening you are kids
kids have a very different relationship
with technology than adults why because
they're less good at this
adult deferred gratification kind of
control so impulse is closer to behavior
the urge comes and they can't resist it
you know you put a cookie out on the
table and say I'm going to leave the
room for five minutes if you don't eat
that you could have three of them and
when you come back it's gone no I didn't
need it somebody else right that's how
kids are where does the stress
from where you know we've heard about
even if your phone is on the table that
it that it can create stress or act on
us where is that coming from
well you're just feeling the impulse
it's a reminder it's like when somebody
pulls their phone out of their pocket
you do the same thing it just brings it
back into awareness and makes you think
hey I could check my phone now what did
we use to interrupt ourselves with
before we had these little interrupts
interruption bundles in our pockets
meaningful conversations walks on the
beach looking at the sky were we more
interesting before these phones were
interrupting us all the time I mean is
there is there a real de munition in
quality of life do you think as a result
of these yes and no what I wouldn't say
diminished I would just say different
one of the things I've noticed in this
day of no devices is that when I do
transitions when I get up to from
reading and go make a cup of coffee
that's when I'm reaching for the phone
is that one of the first things you have
to sort of figure out is what are the
trig triggering moments yes because
you're good at staying on task you have
all of this learning you have set goals
and you're good at accomplishing them
and then suddenly there's a transition
it's a moment when impulse is more
likely you know to find its way to the
surface and you let down your guard
you're not you know your working memory
the part of your brain that says you
stay on task this is what you're doing
has relaxed for a moment what I love
about knowing about dopamine in those
grooves you were talking about is that I
then know that it's that I that I should
entrancing from one room to another
because I'm I'm deepening those grooves
by checking it even though I've got
nothing I'm doing specially and as I
walk from one room to the other but I am
aware that the more I check the more I'm
gonna want to check right and and if you
notice how it feels the less you check
the better you'll feel so the whole
thing you know a lot of it is really
about understanding how we work and and
then deciding what you really want so
you practice mindfulness you've thought
about it a lot so do you still battle
this self interrupting digital addiction
yourself it's a it's exactly the same
for me my biology is exactly the same in
the same way that you know I'd rather
eat food that's unhealthy or sometimes
not exercise so the mindfulness gives me
choices but it doesn't change biology
and it doesn't prescribe anything
actually I might be in a situation where
I wouldn't be using my phone and by
paying attention by actually noticing
what's going on I might think you know
what in this moment even though it's not
my rule I'm going to do it for this
reason so I make better choices going
back to this idea that there are wonders
and connectivity and opening yourselves
up to you know all the world has to
offer through connectivity of the
Internet or through your phones should
one set aside time for that in other
words time to kind of have a digital
walkabout where you can do this kind of
discovery and by setting a discrete time
you maybe gain some control over it I
think that it has a value just like so I
teach mindfulness so people would say
well does your mind never wander and I
hope not you know I I hope that my mind
wanders often because that's when we're
creative that's when things that are
outside the box come into awareness
sometimes our best ideas happen when
we're wandering but if it's a steady
diet if there's nothing but that
happening then it's not healthy devices
are no different what is the benefit of
mindfulness in its most straightforward
aspect mindfulness is training attention
it makes attention stronger so you're
able to notice what's happening make
better choices but there's something
else that's more important that happens
when you train attention this way the
attention doesn't just become like more
more mobile we don't just have better
control over it but it becomes brighter
more clear more robust so that when we
look at the sky we don't just see the
sky you know with half of our attention
but it's blue it it it's clear it
reaches it means something when we look
into another person's
we we don't just see them kind of
through a haze of partial attention we
really experience them we connect so the
most important thing about mindfulness
isn't just that it lets us move our
attention where we want to to be more
productive it's that we use our
attention to find depth and meaning and
connection in our life and that's what
really matters most so mindfulness not
only helps us train our attention to
resist this digital siren song but the
things that we do then put our attention
towards are where we are more keyed in
to that than we would be more connected
we experience it more fully if you're
eating something you actually taste it
and and feel that complexity if we're
talking to somebody you realize how
complicated this story that they're
telling is and you feel their feelings
you connect better after a day of dental
digital interruption you feel almost
like a wraith from the Lord of the Rings
which are these which is to say a person
who walks through the earth but is
hollow inside right the mindfulness
you're talking about not only helps you
not be brave like but also but be
actually even more rich in your
experience than you would have been at
the beginning it's the opposite of that
experience of thinning out and you know
everybody wonders what is this
mindfulness thing why are people nuts
about it attentional training who needs
it but the thing that people don't say
although if you ask questions you'll
you'll find that it's right under the
surface is that the real payoff is in
finding that your life has a richness
and meaning and a quality of depth that
you hadn't noticed before or that you
had begin to lose so as we go through
life and we get used to what we do and
we kind of you know we've seen it all we
begin to feel a little bit more shallow
like less connected to the root of
things and mindfulness undoes that
that's why people are so passionate
about it should we teach
attention training the way we teach
physical fitness in school you are
preaching to the choir here absolutely
and schools are catching on there's more
and more interest and and more and more
schools lots of schools in the
Philadelphia area where I work are
teaching their students mindfulness how
should we think of attention is that the
is that the unit of measurement we
should really be talking about here is
attention at a husband it gotta get more
of it how to hold on to it is that the
key well the thing that devices take
from us is a kind of a stability of
attention and the ability to have a full
complete focus
so when attention is drawn here and
there over and over again it becomes
fragmented sort of piecemeal it doesn't
feel all of one thing it doesn't it
doesn't stay still anymore
and and our experience of the whole
world becomes fragmented in that same
way the solution we're talking about
here is changing your worldview not just
the view on the screen of your of your
digital device right and that's why
mindfulness is such a big deal by
learning to have attention be stable and
open and more receptive we find that
we're living in a room in a world that's
deeper and richer and more fulfilling
the thing that I really worry about with
these devices isn't that they're making
it harder for me to pay attention
although they are but what's happening
to the next generation because we know
that these devices aren't just
distracting them but they're actually
changing the way that their brain works
in fact changing the structure of their
brains and so they're going to use those
brains to make the next generation of
devices which is going to change the
next generation of brains and so we've
kind of inserted ourself into the
process of evolution so that we're
changing the whole way that our brains
and our lives develop and evolve we're
messing with the hardware that we use to
have a life and we have no idea what
we're doing so what is that what it
describes then is we are that we're just
skittering
and and setting up a future where we're
just skittering along the tops of things
because if as we all know in our bones
that the only way you can really know
something and do something and do it
well is if you if you do it at this deep
level and what you're suggesting is
we're training ourselves to be incapable
of ever getting to that deep level right
we're creating future generations whose
brains will be primed to use even more
effective devices